leigh johnson est l'homme qui a tenu
tête à moneteau le jardinier de 46 ans
est atteint d'un cancer incurable
il a vaporisé des centaines de litres de
round up un herbicides à base de
glyphosate
il est maintenant convaincu que c'est la
cause de son cancer en août dernier un
jury américain lui a donné raison et a
condamné le fabricant monson tôt dans
une entrevue exclusive accordée à radio
canada leigh johnson dit espérer que ce
verdict amènera des changements et qui
l'incitera à faire plus de recherche
son voeu sera peut-être exaucé lors du
procès des documents internes ont révélé
que certaines études auraient été
manipulés par le fabricant une coalition
d'organismes dont équiterre et
ecojustice crois que santé canada doit
revoir tout le processus
lemoine santo donc celui qui va le
produit aurait fait en sorte que ces
études là arrivent aux conclusions qui
faisait son affaire et c'est ces études
là que le site santé canada lorsqu'il
parle de cet enjeu du cancer en lien
avec le glyphosate dans un courriel un
porte parole de la ministre a fait
savoir que ces informations sont
troublantes et que des scientifiques de
santé canada mène actuellement une
nouvelle analyse des centaines d'études
sur le sujet la ministre ne ferme pas la
porte à une révision par des experts
indépendants
mais rien de concret pour l'instant et
le produit restera vraisemblablement sur
le marché en attendant monsanto
maintenant détenu par la multinationale
behe a fait appel du verdict aux états
unis la multinationale nous dit n'avoir
en aucune façon tenter d'influer sur le
résultat des études et défend toujours
le glyphosate
c'est leur slogan répond leigh johnson
le père de famille dont les jours sont
maintenant comptés dit qu'au moins s'il
meurt ce ne sera pas en vain ici sylvie
fournira du canada montréal